so my name is Andre and I would like to
talk about prototyping with code it's
not a super technical talk it's more of
you know what I've learned talk and this
is the plan for the talk you'll be
answering these three questions why to
experiment why prototype why is it
important how do we actually implement
it specifically some of the code tricks
and the most sneaky question so what so
what every prototype what do we get from
it where some of the outcomes and I will
start with a story
in 2012 I've joined this startup called
hey mousse and I joined actually as a
Java developer I used to be a job for
back in the days and I joined because it
was like a very challenging job we were
writing our own advertisement network so
we had to handle huge amounts of traffic
and it was very challenging and
interesting and the thing is that six
months later after we've solved all
those you know hard problems on the back
end and we've built super cool and fancy
architectures the company flopped just
just closed you know we've done all that
hard work and then nothing I you know I
didn't stop there I went to work further
in startups in outsourcing companies in
large enterprises as an engineer as a
team lead and eventually is a product
manager but mostly focusing on startups
and right now I'm on sabbatical and I'm
doing this two projects one is called
code podcast it's about generic concepts
in programming and this new project of
mine is called poly chops and it is
about helping musicians practice and you
know getting more out of their practice
but getting back to hey mousse like what
happened why like we worked so well and
the team was great you know some of
those people are now senior engineers in
Microsoft some of them are CEOs in you
know
in larger companies what happened well
once I've looked into what we are doing
in outsourcing companies and in
enterprise companies I realized that we
are basically doing same things in
start-up especially now with the jl
culture being everywhere you know we
have something like a product person
maybe it's a CEO in a start-up or
product manager which comes with the
spec and then the spec goes into
development or first to design then to
development then to QA and virtually the
code gets into production so this
process is the same but results vary you
know enterprise large enterprises don't
close every six months outsourcing
companies don't do that either so what's
different and the most important thing
that I've noticed is that the context is
different now think about it if you are
working on a product who of you thinks
that the product that you're working on
has just too many features there are
some hands all right and who thinks that
you know there is just maybe one or two
feature that we definitely need to
implement you know to advance the
product and you know to make it the
product better few hands the thing is
that for me often times when I would ask
these two questions to the team those
hands that come up they would be from
the same people so I was like huh the
same people say that their product has
too many features and also they want
more features to build like what
happened where is this coming from why
is it happening and the the conclusion
that they came up with is that
outsourcing companies what they have is
that they have the context of certainty
you know there is a customer that comes
to you as an outsourcer and says this is
the spec implement it in the best
possible way go into this and in a
start-up we don't have this luxury
usually you know they're they're just
vague signals from the market and
you know we probably know what we want
to build and which problem we want to
solve but not really but still we used
the same process we kind of there is a
product manager that comes up with a
spec though brings it to design and now
you know or developers and now build it
and imagine what it is like to be this
person I mean they have to pretend that
you know they understand the world
perfectly and they can foresee the
future and know the customer you know
and yeah they basically most of the time
have to pretend because there is a lot
of uncertainty on the market and what we
end up with is we end up doing safer
bets that we probably could have and you
know 90% of startups most of the time
fail so I was thinking about this is
there a better way is there something
that we can do different thing turns out
there is a way and thinking about
uncertainty in a broader context I think
in the start we have uncertainty coming
from three big places it's the market
you know what is our demographics how
big is the market how much are they
willing to pay at the product you know
what is the problem that cost that our
customers have what is the solution that
we can offer them and the implementation
like can we even build this product for
instance you know we know that a pill
that will cure cancer probably will find
the market you know that's not it's not
something we need to test but can we
actually create this pill is it possible
from an implementation standpoint is a
question that we need to ask and so
instead of this execution mindset that
we are using when building features from
specs I think we need to change our
focus and first solve the uncertainty
part so the goal of the research mode I
believe should be reducing uncertainty
rather than implementing an ideal
working feature so think about it in
this way you know 90% of startups fail
what if you launch
100 or like what we launched 10 products
and one of them succeeds that's all we
need
let's print basically the mindset behind
prototyping here is an example from my
personal project
Porter jobs which is you know it started
off as a metronome but with the weird
interface a circle interface and it was
you know unusual and I didn't know
whether it would help people practice
better musicians whether it would be
inspiring whether how would it work even
will it work with you know in the web
browser or should I build native apps I
had all those questions and there could
be a possibility of me just going
forward and you know creating a spec and
to end and build in it but instead I
chose a different way I chose a way of
you know doing research and research
when we are talking about research the
market research is usually done just on
in an Excel spreadsheet and using Google
search product and implementation
research is something else here we
oftentimes need to expose something to
to people and to understand whether they
get it whether we get it and so on and
so forth and it turns out that the best
tool that we as humanity have so far for
reducing uncertainty is scientific
method you know there is you know it's
not ideal we have we as humans have
biases and so on and so forth but this
is the best thing we have so what is a
scientific method we basically come up
with the hypothesis we come up with an
experiment then we run this experiment
and we see whether it failed or
succeeded and prototypes is a way to run
those experiments basically prototypes
are carefully constructed illusions that
will help us verify whether hypothesis
is true or false nothing else it's not a
product that we will sell immediately
you know it's not an ideal
implementation it's just an illusion
like a movie set or a theater stage and
I believe that in order to build
successfully prototypes we have to kind
put our best selves our technical best
selves on the shelf for a while and you
know take a step back because we as
engineers as designers as product
managers just want to you know do the
best stuff designers want to build pixel
perfect mock-ups developers want to
build architectures and so on and so
forth
but for for prototypes we kind of need
to become rookie's again we want to
become beginners because experts often
make mistakes in uncertainty in the
context of uncertainty and there is
research that confirms that because
experts you know they know what they
need to do whereas rookies usually don't
know what they need to do and so they
seek constant feedback and this is a
very valuable trade experts design
architectures rookies they are happy
with something that works and this is
what we are looking for experts
approximate in the future
rookies just live in the moment experts
have reputations at stake and so you
know they're very invested in whatever
solution they are offering and they tend
to double down the solution even if it
doesn't work whereas rookie is another
invested they basically don't care so to
sum up and explain it to a teenage and
self instead of being this guy or girl
you want to be kind of this person like
I don't know how do we do that what are
some of the concrete tools and practices
that we can use in order to achieve that
well I believe the most important part
is even before we start prototyping even
before we write the first line of code
or build the first video to to test
something we need to think about where
we will find feedback on that thing that
we are testing whether we will go online
and search for feedback online maybe
whether we will invite someone to the
office we need to have this in mind we
being to have the end in mind before we
start doing anything and the shorter the
feedback
cycle of the better you know
theoretically in this company I was
working at hey mousse we did have the
feedback cycle you know it was just you
know six months or whatever four months
long and at the end of the feedback
cycle we just found out that we don't
have any money in the bank yeah that's
also a feedback cycle it's just very
well so what we need to do is we need to
shorten the feedback cycle here is an
example from another star Bobby was
working at it's a b2b startup that sells
the product to kind of large enterprises
what we've built is a piece of software
that allows you to drag-and-drop create
mobile applications and those mobile
applications they extract data in the
background from an actual web
application so if you have an old CRM
system or an old Salesforce system that
doesn't work on your phone you can build
a nice mobile app in a matter of you
know a couple of hours and you know it's
nice product but the thing is that in
large enterprises the sales cycle is at
least six months that means that we get
to build whatever our fantasy allows us
during those six months you know to just
then later realize that it was all just
you know a dream we don't need this and
so what did we do we created an internal
team that would serve the customer but
would also build just you know random
applications that we would find random
use cases and they would just do that
and that allowed us to have super short
feedback cycle because there was a
dedicated team that was using the
product and feeding as super early
feedback that was great another example
from pork chops
we started with super early on with
publishing videos on reddit and so on so
forth asking people for feedback and
maybe asking for engagement so some of
the people agreed to have a call with us
for instance and you know have a
conversation about how they practice or
add the types of metronomes they use and
so on so forth and those conversations
they actually yielded create results and
that leads me to the next point seek
qualitative feedback because
quantitative feedback oftentimes leads
to local optimizations
would I mean by that quantitative
feedback only gives you an answer yes or
no is the green button better than the
red button you know this kind of
questions we can answer with data but
qualitative qualitative data can kind of
the person can tell you hey I don't need
the button here you know this is
something that you can automate
completely and this open opens your mind
to a completely different perspective
one example of a company that is heavily
reliant on quantitative data and on a/b
testing is booking comm you know I think
there is space for improvement on the
website sorry Rachel
now here is a story from from one of the
people that we did an interview with so
remember we started Polly Jobs as a
metronome application you know just a
metronome and we interviewed one person
and they said hey can I export the sound
of the metronome and have it like as an
audio file we were like why why would
you do that this is so backwards like
why would you do that with the metronome
and it was like no no I just want to put
it in a digital audio workstation and
then record myself on top of the
metronome and then listen back and hear
if I'm on time or not we were like wow
this is actually genius like hey can we
can we ask 15 more people if they do the
same and turns out yes people just turn
on the metronome put the whatever
recorder app on their phone record
themselves playing and then listen back
to understand whether they are on time
or not and so we were like hey we can
just build this in the app like you
don't need to have a separate record a
separate metronome we can show you the
beads we can show you you know the
waveform everything all in one place
so this is this was super insightful and
we would never get this information
built just a be testing like we would we
wouldn't have even this idea now another
important principle is the interface in
the prototype is everything and I do
mean interface
in a very broad sense so for instance in
polytopes the interface is the graphical
user interface but it is also the sound
because the user also perceives the
sound in the app in an API the interface
is your documentation that describes all
the methods in an API speaking about API
is in productive mobile at some point
which is we decided to rewrite some of
the APIs that we exposed to up Creators
and so instead of going the usual way of
me as a product manager just packing the
whole thing very thoroughly and then
giving it to developers to implement we
went a different route we created a
small file with the documentation where
all the methods were written and all
their signatures were described and then
we took that API and we kind of built we
fake build those apps with the persons
with the people that we're using the
application to build actual mobile apps
to build mobile apps on paper so to say
you know and all the data that would be
processed in the API we did all the
processing also on paper by ourselves
and so we did maybe five or six
iterations before we understood okay
this is the ideal API we can actually
serve you know 90% of the use cases that
we want to cover let's pack it and build
it so we kind of saved a lot of time
using that I didn't know the sound would
work but this is the very first
prototype of polytopes and is just a
video and usually I coded it in flash it
was like friends look at it it's perfect
it's your future metal and people said
yeah we can understand polyrhythms you
know we can understand two over three
and was like yeah that's that's the
purpose and this is how polish ops looks
now and you know it's not much different
even though on this thing I spent maybe
10 minutes and this thing I spent maybe
a month
all right and talking about faking you
know we are all taught especially as
developers to build nice architectures
too we had Gang of Four design patterns
and so on and so forth but the thing is
that when you are building prototypes
you kind of accumulate a set of patterns
there is the opposite of whatever we got
to do and this is a very interesting so
for instance in pawn shops we wanted at
some point to test multiple users
interacting with each other and instead
of building the proper identification
which is you know very risky very
expensive takes a lot of time you need
to test it you need to pen tested it we
just you know we said okay it's a
prototype and we will just save a token
or a user ID in local storage and we
will send it with every request and bam
we have users that are authenticated you
know we will send them the official memo
saying hey don't don't use it don't put
any sensitive data there but it was
enough to test the concept and kind of
over time you accumulate those kind of
patterns and it's important to think
about it as a library now several minor
tips use a design system you know
because you don't yeah because you don't
want to spend your mental energy and
time thinking through every possible
interaction in your app certainly we did
this mistake because initially we build
the app from scratch and we came up with
all the buttons and you know we built
super customer interface but then we
found out that we need to build
notifications and menus and you know
parent-child views and dropdowns and
what do you do do you design it all from
scratch
no it's just easier if you use something
ready-made material is a good example at
least of you know way of documenting
stuff where everything is very clear you
can take it and use it still
no seriously don't steal from your
competitors though because whatever
they've built they probably have already
tested and probably works you don't need
to prototype it you know it works just
copy but still from other industries
from you know parallel industries so for
example this feature with recording and
playing back was heavily inspired by
digital audio workstations like logic
and 9 Bolton and sounds fault but it's
massively simplified so you know you
don't just copied one to one but you
still have ideas you will go into depth
especially as engineers and it's ok so
one example of it is we are all taught
this don't repeat yourself principal you
know
god forbid you copied copy paste the
code two times in while prototyping I've
noticed that I have a rule that I copy
the code at least three times before I
abstract it out and create an
abstraction on top of it at least three
times
why because over time you see that you
know the code diverges something that
you saw there is similar is actually
different and you know after you've
copied the code maybe three to five
times and you see that it's completely
the same then you can abstract it out
and create something on top of it but
the good thing with copying as well even
if they do diverge but maybe just a
little your shape of abstraction is
super clear because you know ok I just
need these two parameters that are
custom and everything else is the same I
know how to build my abstraction because
we don't refactor and because we don't
have specs just don't write tests don't
bother
seriously you will throw them away now
if this slide would be taken out of
context
and go on Twitter tonight I know all
your faces right abstract out libraries
and frameworks this is the only thing
that you probably do want to abstract
out because for instance something we
did in Poli Jobs is we started using
Redux because because we had a lot of
logic on the front end with all those
metronomes and stuff but then we
understood that it would be safer -
safer and faster to sink some of the
data with Apollo and graph QL so we had
two competing frameworks in the same
prototype which is a huge no-no but we
could do that because our dumb
components do you know about the
rapper's they didn't know about where
the data comes from because all of this
stuff was abstracted another example we
you we kind of got used to making folder
structures that are following a
framework such as you know we have
action creators and reducers and
middleware files or folders well this is
something you also want to avoid I mean
generally in development but especially
in prototypes because what you want to
do at some point is maybe to switch the
library or you know take it away
completely so it's a good idea to maybe
think in terms of your domain model
rather than the framework structure so
for instance in rails it's very you know
it's very strict you have to use the
controllers and stuff like that I mean
consider maybe not doing that if you
will switch at some point right but do
not go bankrupt you know especially
under pressure it's very easy to do you
show a prototype to your boss and
they're like okay great it works let's
just put it in the production like no be
clear with your superior officers or
whatever that this code is a prototype
and it's not an actual thing it will
help you to validate your hypothesis and
to experiment and to understand the
direction but it's not production code
so whenever you decide that experiment
succeeded and you want to keep the
prototype just come back and rewrite it
and now but then you know we are
borrowing the time from the future why
do you even bother writing you know bad
practice code if we will rewrite it well
the thing is that a lot of experiments
some of the experiments will fail and so
some of the code you will just throw
away or maybe some of the experiments
will show you some inconclusive results
but they will definitely point you in
the right direction and you will have to
maybe rebuild something differently
compared to how you did it in a
prototype so we still get some value
there to sum up all the all the all that
was said so far we have two contacts in
the company we have the context of
certainty and the context of uncertainty
certainty is when your customer in a non
source company comes to you and says
this is the spec implement they have
already resolved all the uncertainty you
know you don't have to resolve it
uncertainty context is when you know
your product manager tries to guess
which feature is good would best serve
your customers and in those two contexts
we have two different mechanisms that we
can use in a certainty context we just
go for implementation you know best code
possible best mock-ups possible in an
uncertainty context we go in the
opposite direction we want to do
research we went to the exploration and
so we want to also embrace different
mindsets you know we don't want to be
hardcore designers or developers or
product managers when we are in an
uncertainty context we just want to
explore we're going to be open-minded so
what like what are the results you know
show me the money
I think I think before I talk about
results I think it's important to
mention that what I'm talking about
right now is decision quality I'm not
talking about outcomes so far an example
is you know because we are dealing with
uncertainty we can just guess one one
time write us back and be right and get
huge output from that but maybe the
probability of this was initially just
10% and we got lucky or we can do all
the best possible research and we can
just with the probability of 90% of
success of success we got into the rest
of the 10% and we failed you know so I
think it's important to think about
decision quality versus the outcome
quality as well but talking about
outcomes real quick which is not as
and for instance in productive mobile
after we spit up the the feedback cycle
and we've implemented all the changes
we've started the platform started
covering maybe 90% of use cases instead
of initial 20 and those 90% of use cases
we started covering in a matter of days
rather than weeks so you know it's a
huge improvement and what's the most
important thing about that is that we
didn't implement maybe you know on
average five specs every half a year so
those specs be just you know we
experimented we explored them and we
understood that we rather don't
understand them we don't understand the
customer or you know something is off
and that there is actually a huge bin we
didn't do some work you know it's great
all right I think I don't have much time
but if you are willing to talk to you to
your stakeholders and if you want to
understand how to sell of all that
approach there is some information in
the material in the article that I put
after the talk and I hope you will get
to apply some of those learnings and I
hope you will build great products and
at some point I too will be one of your
happy customers
[Applause]